It is, out of every episode, it's the lowest
rated one. It's called The Underdwellers,
Season One, episodes six.
Sounds awesome.
I know it's a great name.
It's not that awesome.
It is colloquially in my apartment known as the
episode where everybody in Gotham is
just a little high, just a little...
Today. We're going to talk about the best moments
from Batman, the animated series. And to start us
off, we are going to ask Nina to tell us about the
episode that we told her to watch. Because this
is a show that she didn't watch and that's fine
because it was on before she was born I think.
When was it on?
That came on in like the early, maybe you
were like an infant when this show was on.
When did it start? You have to know this...
92, 93.
I was born in 1990. I'm not, I'm not...
You have a wonky sense of time because
you've been alive for centuries.
I've been alive for so long.
No, I just, I don't want to be like the
gen Z of this channel, because I'm not.
No, but to be fair, to be perfectly fair.
Yep.
This is a show you haven't seen and that's okay.
No.
Because, it was well before your time.
It's a show. I feel when I sat down to watch this
episode, it was a show that I felt was a cultural
osmosis thing because I have just seen clips of it
used in many other kind of context and properties
for so long. The way Batman's drawn in Batman the
Animated Series is super iconic. And I feel that's
the way I've always seen a cartoon
Batman look, does that make sense?
Yes.
It's always been like that depiction.
That's what it is right.
Right. Yeah. There have been
other Batman shows and stuff,
but it's like that's the one I understand.
It's, for me, mine is the super friend
style Batman because when I was a kid.
Oh yeah?
Batman and Robin would team up with Scooby-Doo.
Yeah.
And it would just be goofy and dumb. And there
was Adam West Batman. So that was Batman for
me. So then when this show came on, when I was in
elementary school, I was, oh my God. And it just
blew the brain out of the back of my head.
It was good so.
They let you in an elementary
school in your fifties?
Yes. I'm incredibly stupid.
That tracks, go ahead.
But, Nina, we got this list-
Can we put up a picture of
my spirit animal, boo boo the fool?
Anyway. Yeah. So we got this list.
We have this list on luper.com and one of the
first ones on here is the episode, Heart of Ice,
particularly the snow globe, which you'll see
at the end of the episode. So that was the one.
Oh, the one where it turns out
that St. Elsewhere was all...
Yeah, it was all...
It all happened in Batman the animated series. No.
So you, Brian told me to watch this episode. I'm
just going to, because I've already had my dirty
laundry hung out to dry. That's what happened.
It's fine.
And I'm so excited for the
comments on this one. Yikes.
It's Fine.
So I did watch Heart of Ice. Really good episode.
Yeah.
And yeah, I mean, Mr. Freeze is, as you both told
me, a pretty lame villain, all things considered,
especially in other depictions, but this
was a very perfectly contained 22 minute
saga of a guy. It was also very depressing.
You know, he loses his wife. He just wants
to make Ferris Doyle, right?
Who's voiced by Mark Hamill,
the evil corrupt CEO of GothCorp,
he wants to make him suffer.
So Mark Hamill is well known as being
the voice of the joker on the show.
Right.
But before he got that gig regularly,
he did this role because of the
way that they recorded this off.
Oh, dip. Okay. Because yeah...
Yeah. He had this role first and then Tim Curry
was supposed to be the joker.
I think this is how it went.
Okay.
And then for either Tim Curry had to drop out or
they just decided it wasn't a good fit either way.
Mark Hamill got the role, I
think, after this. And so yeah.
Right.
But yes.
Well I know chronologically this series comes
later, but I like to call that Law and Order
Syndrome or early in Law and Order, Special
Victims Unit, an actress played a woman accused of
assaulting a male dancer and then two seasons
later she was the district attorney. And I was...
Ha, ha, ha. She really, she really...
What a glow up for this woman. Yeah.
That didn't last very long. That's amazing.
What a glow up.
So yeah.
The system works you guys.
Really does. She was reformed.
So yeah. So I watched
Heart of Ice, really solid episode. So Batman
gets a cold from a freeze gun, which I'm not,
from an epidemiology standpoint, I don't
know if that really tracks, but whatever...
It works.
It's okay. It's pretty - right?
But the best...
It lowered his immune system.
Yeah.
And he caught a cold.
Right.
That's why they call it a cold.
Okay, science.
So, but the best part of the episode by far
is that the chicken soup that Alfred gives to
Batman slash Bruce Wayne is what ends
up defeating Mr. Freeze. And I was, oh,
it's like chicken soup for the
cold soul or something like...
Ooh.
Set up. Pay off.
Set up and payoff.
It's beautiful, its beautiful.
But it was just such a doofy little
piece of setup and payoff. And I just,
I loved it. It was extremely fun.
Yeah.
Yeah. Nice little bite size episode. I mean
animation's always shorter, right. Even,
if a full length animated movie is never more
than 90 minutes, because it just takes so long.
Often, yeah.
Logistically. Yeah.
Right.
Yeah. It's a very labor
intensive process, but yeah.
Super fun episode. Thanks for telling me to
watch it. I want to go back and watch more.
You're welcome. It was-
Yeah.
One of the things that we talked about a
little bit in our chat before we hopped
on here was the fact that, and you
alluded to this just a minute ago
that, prior to this, Mr. Freeze
was just a very lame villain.
Mm-hmm.
This backstory,
this character wasn't really in place. And
so when they were making this episode, they
wrote a tragic villain and he's really cold pun
intended and very emotionally cut off because of-
Yeah.
The accident that he suffered through-
Right. Doesn't he say he really
can't feel anything anymore because
he has to live in the subzero suit because he
fell into his own cold research. Yeah. Science.
He's just very sad all the time.
Yeah.
It's a beautiful little metaphor
and it's just kind of this weirdly,
it's a mini movie. It's a 22 minute mini movie.
Yeah.
And it's perfect. It's got a great
three act structure. You've got
your main antagonist, your secondary antagonist,
the set up, the payoff with the chicken soup.
It's just perfect. And it's one of those...
Really good voice acting. a really
solid voice acting across the board.
Amazing voice acting.
And just that sad moment of Dr. Freeze in his
jail cell, apologizing to his late wife for not
getting the revenge that he promised and Batman
even feels bad about it. And you're like, aw wow.
Everything in the show is generally a gigantic
bummer. And that's why it's so... It's really
cool because at the time this was groundbreaking
at the time because they were trying to put...
They were trying to do this noir kind of more
adult look at Batman, but do it for a kid's show.
Right.
And they had to fight standards
and practices all the time.
That's the tone that they were
going for then they nailed it.
They had to argue to let Batman punch people.
They had to argue to let bad guys have guns.
Right.
Yeah.
That black man wouldn't get shot by.
Right.
Just all these things that we take for granted as
stuff that you can kind of get away with in most
things in media. At that time it was just,
you can't do that. This is a
kid show, this is for children.
Right.
What are you doing? And so, the fact
that it can end tragically and we're
going to talk more about at this
stuff in a few minutes, but yeah,
this is one of my favorites. I'm excited you
finally saw it and I'm excited that you're
definitely going to watch more. We're we're
going to have more conversations about it.
Yeah. Yeah, I mean, you're going to message
me every day and ask if I have, so I
already wanted to, but now I'm going to get
bullied about it. So extra incentive for me.
That's what I do. I bully people
at work to watch cartoons I like.
The way that the tables have turned on our lives,
collectively that we are now the ones bullying
people into watching Batman instead of...
Yes.
Yes, this is not what it
was like when I was a kid.
Tom. Tom, what about you? What is,
what is your pick from this list?
I'm glad you asked Brian. So I don't know. I feel
like this, the show has such a huge following
and such a passionate following that kind of
all of the best episodes have kind of been,
have been talked about, there were only what,
there were four seasons, there were
109 episodes, something like that?
Something, it was, I think
there were three seasons on Fox
and then it moved to WB and they changed
the animation style to modernize it.
Okay.
And that was the fourth season. So
that's why, if you look in HBO Max,
the first couple of seasons look very
classic, very kind of retro styling.
Classic, yeah.
And then the final season's very much in the
vein of the Justice League unlimited cartoon,
the Superman animated series
cartoon, it's a style by then.
Yeah.
So everything kind of got really streamlined into
this one style. But anyway,
I interrupted you. Go ahead.
No, not at all. We're talking about a thing
we're excited about and things Batman.
What I decided that I wanted to do was I
put a little bit of sauce on the prompt.
Okay.
I put some sauce on it Brian.
Good.
And what I decided to do was to try and find,
instead of the best episode, I decided I
wanted to find redemption for the worst one.
I think I know what the worst one is.
I would... What do you think
it is? Because I went to IMDB,
I looked it up, I found which
one has the lowest rating.
I have two choices.
Okay, hit me.
I have two choices for what
this is. One is Tyger, Tyger.
Ooh, interesting. Okay.
Was that it?
That's not it.
Where they turned cat woman
into a cat woman and it sucks.
I mean, I don't.
That was a low point for me, that one.
See any reason why that would suck. That sounds...
That one was one of them. I think the
one where I think his name was Nostromos
or something where Batman takes on a grifter,
who's all about astrology. That was another one.
Ooh, that's great.
That was kind of... that one?
No, it's not that one? Okay.
Not that one.
Is it that one with, is it I've got
Batman in my basement. Is it that one?
No, but I thought about that one.
Is it the one where they go down into the sewers?
It is.
With the sewer king guy? Okay.
It is the one with the sewer king.
I knew it was one of those, one of those ones.
There's an episode with a
sewer king, like mole people?
Yeah. He abducts a bunch of kids.
Tom, tell us about this episode.
I want to watch this one.
I would love to. So it is,
it's out of every episode,
it's the lowest rated one. It's called
the Underdwellers season one episode six.
Sounds awesome.
I know it's a great name. It is colloquially
in my apartment known as the episode
where everybody in Gotham is just
a little high. They just a little,
not all the way high, not lie on the couch high,
but definitely kind of spacey. The episode-
Like a few too many CBD gummies.
Didn't actively go further than that.
Yeah, Yeah. Yeah. There wasn't supposed to be
THC in this, but I feel whoo. So the episode
starts out with a lady gets her purse stolen by
somebody small and she says a leprechaun did it.
And then Batman runs after this small person.
The alleged leprechaun?
And loses them and then goes back to the bat cave
and says, I think a leprechaun stole a purse. And
Alfred at this point is listening to classical
music, but he's like bopping out to it.
He's having a groovy time doing this.
And then Alfred says, it probably wasn't
a leprechaun though right? And Batman says,
maybe I need a rest. And then Alfred says,
maybe you need a rest. And then Batman
says, I think it was a leprechaun and...
It's not how I remember this.
I'm giving you a condensed version.
You're paraphrasing it, okay.
It turns out the leprechaun thing, by the
way, just a real zebra of a diagnosis,
if you're asking me, they find a small guy
and he say, you know what, I probably...
It turns out of course, it's actually a kid.
The kid is part of a Dickensian orphan sewer
gang being run by a real hat on the hat,
original villain named the sewer king,
who was played by an actor named
Michael Pataki, who was a character
actor who actually, he played a goon in the
original, 1966 Batman TV show with Adam West.
Yes.
He was one of king tuts, goons.
also a Klingon in The Trouble
with Tribbles episode of Star Trek.
Nina, have you watched Star Trek yet?
No Tom, I haven't.
What's actor's name?
Michael Palaki. He's the one in the... Or Pataki,
excuse me. He is the one in the bar who says that
the enterprise should be hauled away as garbage.
That guy. You know what I'm talking about?
Okay, but it's not one of the three Klingons who
came back in Deep Space Nine to team up with Dax.
No, But he did show up again in
Next Generation as a different character...
It doesn't matter, I'm getting off topic.
Doesn't matter, sorry, sorry.
Point is, the guys can't make-
We never get off topic on this
show. So that's really unacceptable.
It's never happened before. This is unprecedented.
He's got a riding cloak. He's got glasses with one
lens blacked out and a walking stick and he
doesn't let the children speak. He just sends
them out to steal him. Very Studio Ghibli looking
food, this delicious cartoon food. And he owns at
minimum eight alligators. It's not clear how
many alligators he has in total. I thought I
clocked eight of them. They've all got alligator
collars. It's unclear where he is getting those.
I think the Dickensian orphans are probably
producing them in a sweat shop
somewhere, below the surface.
I thought you meant as like a
biological thing. I was... Okay so...
No, the collars.
The real winning detail of the episode for me
is that we find out two things that the
bat mobile can do, that I was not aware of
up until this point. The first one is that
it can transform into a garbage dumpster.
Nice.
As a form of disguise, which is what it is. And
then the second one is that it has like a builtin,
tiny television screen that appears to be that
Batman finds one of the kids and he brings him
back to Wayne Manor and on the drive over, I
guess, to stop the kid from realizing where
he is going, he pops out this little television
screen in the dashboard of the car and it plays
a spirally thing. And then it puts the kid to
sleep. So Batman has a kid's sleep machine.
Well, didn't we actually see that
in Batman Begins. Didn't he have
something like that in the Bat mobile to put
Rachel to sleep when they were going to the
bat cave, or was she suffering like that?
No, she was drugged up on the fear gas
and she was about to die. It's just...
I don't really love the idea of a forced sleep
machine in a bat mobile to be used on the
women and children.
Nope, using it on kids. Yep, no, super weird.
And ladies. No bad, bad idea. Don't do that.
So you were going to redeem
this episode, right Tom?
I was going to try...
You haven't done a great job.
Yeah.
Yeah. It turned out there was
nothing, it's just really bad.
Okay.
Yeah, no, it's a tragedy.
So, very good.
It's one of the alligators.
That's why it's on this list. That
is one of the lesser episodes. Other
ones on this list that we'll briefly
mention. This is about moments from
Batman the Animated Series. So Nina,
you talked about the chicken soup.
Tom, you talked about the bat mobile as dumpster
as your favorite moment from that episode.
I did love that yeah.
That's awesome.
So on this list, we've got the snow
globe from the very end of Heart of Ice,
which is a pretty classic iconic moment.
We've got Batman's identity revealed in
the Strange Secret of Bruce Wayne with a very
old Batman villain that they adapted for the
animated series. Hugo Strange, who shows
up in the Batman Arkham City video game.
Yeah.
He's a very pulpy villain. He's got a thick
German accent and dark glasses. And he is "I vill
capture ze Batman" or whatever he says.
That's it, direct quote.
Yes, thank you. Scenes from Bruce Wayne battling
Batman in the episode Perchance to Dream. So in
that one, Mad Hatter, he captures Batman, sticks
the device on his head. Next thing Batman knows,
he wakes up, he's Bruce Wayne and he's not Batman
anymore. And so he's going through this life. He's
not Batman, but Batman's out there doing stuff,
but he gets to be Bruce Wayne with living parents.
And eventually he freaks out, because
he can't deal with the fact that,
he gets the sense that this isn't real. And he
confronts Batman of this reality. And he figures
out that he thinks he's in a dream. And so Bruce
Wayne is, all right, I'm going to jump off this
high tower now. And Batman's like, if you do
that, you'll die. And he is, I think I'll wake up.
But either way, it's better than living a lie.
And he, stone cold tries to just, he just jumps.
He jumps to his death basically. And then he
wakes up and he beats the bad guy. And it's,
again, it's all a gigantic bummer,
but it's all very thematically,
it's cool stuff. It's cool
stuff for kids to figure out.
That's very, what was that? What was
that? Alan Moore, Superman story?
The gift, what is it, gift for the
man who, the man who has everything.
For the man who has everything.
That's what it's called. Yeah, there's
another one on here. The Batman Unite
where he teams up with the great ghost,
voice by Adam West. Great episode.
Oh yeah.
There's a lot of good ones on here. I went off
menu to pick two of my own favorites, because
again, I was, I want to talk about this show, but
I don't want to pick something from this list.
Just because I know that there's stuff that I
like that I want to bring up. And one of them was
an episode called The Joker's Favor. And
it starts off with this guy named Charlie,
just driving his car, and he's all mad. And
he's, eh, everything stinks. My life is terrible.
And finally he gets cut off by someone
driving a station wagon and he is,
that's it. I'm going to give this guy a piece
of my mind. He's at the end of his rope and he
starts, he drives after this guy who cut
him off. He bumps his car with his car,
which is, in a cartoon, it's fine, but
in reality that's, no you have to call.
Exactly.
You have to call a cop. You have to get the
insurance involved. But anyway, let's pretend
that, that could happen. That you could play
bumper cars with your car. Anyway, he starts
cursing at the driver and then he finds out that
the guy driving it is the Joker and he freaks.
Oh geez.
He freaks out. Because he's, I just started
screaming at the Joker and this great scene
ensues where he's running away from the Joker,
trying to get away and the Joker's following him
and it's this... First of all, it's amazing,
whenever I know you guys don't drive, but when I
drive and I do something goofy, yeah I just threw
you under the bus. Another driving reference.
Hanging some dirty laundry there.
The bus that neither of us can drive.
You're both riding because you don't drive.
But whenever I drive and I do something dumb,
right? I'm, oh this guy's going to see... I don't
want to sit next to him at a light. He's going to
look at me because I just cut them off. And
it's that but a homicidal maniac is coming-
Right, you look over and
it's Tony Soprano, but it...
Right.
And you're like aw.
Or Tony Soprano in Joker makeup. Even scarier.
No, just like someone that you know is trouble.
Yeah.
That's going to seriously come after you.
I don't know if James Gandolfini in clown
makeup is chocolate and peanut butter
quite the way that you think it's,
those are two disparate tastes.
Yeah.
You want to see it.
But it's this amazing moment
because it's one of the first times
in the series that you see someone reacting
to the Joker, who's not Batman. It's someone-
I was going to say. It seems like it's out of the
context of Batman for one second, which is cool.
Right, well for most of the show,
Batman is barely in this episode.
Really?
He shows up the last six minutes to save
the day. And it's basically about this guy.
He after the Joker...
He pisses off the Joker by accident.
He pisses off the Joker. The Joker takes
his ID. He's like, you owe me a favor. Bye.
And then it cuts to two years later and this
dude has moved to Ohio and changed his name.
Oh no.
He gets a phone call from the Joker. He is, I got
that favor. And he is you got the wrong number.
He's no, I got the right number. Here's your whole
family. And again, kids cartoon amazing stuff.
It just so happens, also, this is a really
good episode for a lot of reasons. But-
I love that this episode teaches kids
like witness protection does not work.
They will always find you. Don't bother.
Don't bother.
-you anyway.
You're screwed.
The bad guys will always find you.
You can't hide. Bye kids.
But this also happens to be
the episode that features the
very first, literally the first
appearance of Harley Quinn.
Oh.
Her first appearance ever. And she's just...
how was that on our list? This is a good one.
Well I mean, that's the thing, there's
so much to choose from with this show.
Yeah.
But she's just there in the
Joker's hideout when he's
complaining about his... He's got this
big scheme where he is going to blow up
the police force, because they're doing
a big dinner for commissioner Gordon.
And so Harley Quinn is just there just, yeah,
the commissioner sucks or whatever she says.
Right.
She's this amazing character
who's fully formed from day one.
Right.
In my opinion, a lot of the backstory they've kind
of given her diminishes, kind of her strength of
just this great sassy side character. Who's just
this amazing, extra, extra punch to the Joker. And
I like that Harley has gotten a lot more starring
roles that we've learned more about her generally.
Yeah.
I feel like the backstory that she was
a psychiatrist who fell in love with the Joker
doesn't... and also like an Olympic level gymnast.
These two things don't quite go together for
me, but I'm just, I'm picking nits. Harley's
great. She's a great character. It's great that
she's introducing in this episode. This is a
classic episode. The other one I watched really
briefly, because I've been talking for a while
is it's called Read My Lips. And I've mentioned
before my love of the Ventriloquist and Scarface.
Oh no, oh Brian.
Okay. So, but here's the thing I've got my moment
picked out. So for the last one, the moment was
when the Joker runs this guy down and he's like
hiding from the Joker and you get to see someone
really afraid of the Joker. For this one, there's
the reveal that the big bad guy is a puppet.
And this is the face that they show Batman making
in the episode, I've shared it in our chat.
Aw, aw.
That's the big reveal.
He looks like the dick.
He's straight up just what the...
Is going on. He cannot even deal with what
he's seeing. And I just love it. I love them.
I just started laughing because I was yeah,
if I was a crime fighter and I saw that-
Seriously.
The mob boss who's committing these
amazing heists all over Gotham
was literally a puppet. I
might make that face too.
It seems appropriate.
Yeah. So anyway.
Outstanding.
Good show. Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe.